[Music]
okay well thank you for being here it's
actually it's actually 2,000 restaurants
and more like 2 million burgers a month
but so it's a little strange that I'm
I'm here purporting to be a kind of
business expert because I'm still a
complete freshman in the business world
and I think they're half the people in
the audience probably could teach me
more than I could teach them about how
to how to function in that world and I
definitely have as much learned as
anyone here so ten years ago the last
thing that I would imagine myself doing
was founding a business and and even
laughter than that was founding a food
business because I had essentially no
interest in business and and my only
interest in food was you know just
eating it when I wasn't eating it I was
just not that interested in it
and so I was completely unqualified for
this gig and at the time I had what was
really my dream job I basically had
awesome colleagues I had a research lab
that I loved and great students and
great funding and a very secure job and
I basically my job description was
invent and discover things and that was
literally what my job description was
and it was what I would have created for
myself if I had the choice so why would
I give all that up to do something that
I was unqualified to do
and oh okay a cheesy photograph of
myself that's that's kind of unnerving
okay so so this here is a scenic view of
Mars this is the second best planet in
our solar system and it's probably the
second best planet that we could travel
to in our lifetimes within 50 light
years of Earth okay and it sucks
it it has no breathable air no liquid
water it's winter all the time but
there's no skiing and and dim light and
nothing but rocks and boulders as far as
the eye can see it's a sorry excuse for
a camper for a planet but it's kind of a
good negative control for this we got
the good planet this is a little patch
of planet or if this is this is just a
patch of the Amazon actually and you
won't find anything like this anywhere
within 50 light-years of here we have
liquid water we have air we can breathe
we have mind-boggling biodiversity and
beauty and we take it for granted that
this is just where we live big deal but
we shouldn't you know earth is 4.5
billion years old and when it was 4
billion years old
we couldn't have lived on it for five
minutes there was no breather but there
was no oxygen in the air it was only
when the first land plants appeared
about 400 million years ago that the
oxygen levels got at all into the range
where animals could survive so this is
you know this is not something we can
take for granted and the lives of our
children and future generations
basically depend on how good a job we do
of taking care of this because
there's no alternative and we're doing a
crappy job of it and this is why this is
for all practical purposes the reason
why this plant is in jeopardy which may
sound surprising but it's just true so
there the problem is actually it's not
the problem but the driver of the
problem is we love meat and since
prehistoric times well in prehistoric
times it was essential for survival we
hunted animals to survive because
basically it was a very efficient way of
getting high high in nutrient density
food with relatively little labour and
of course but it didn't scale and today
we don't need meat to survive in fact
people who don't have any meat in their
diets by and large are substantially
healthier than people who do but we love
meat and to satisfy the growing demand
for meat we've built an industry that
today kills 11 cows 15 sheep 17 goats 47
pigs and more than 2000 chickens every
second and using that prehistoric
technology animals to produce these
humongous quantities of meat requires a
huge fraction of Earth's natural
resources and it takes a tremendous toll
on the global environment and I won't
drag you through through all the ways in
which that's true
just say that it's responsible for more
greenhouse gases than every cart car bus
truck train airplane rocket ship boat
all transportation combined it consumes
more water and pollutes more water than
any other industry on earth and it
currently occupies about half of every
square mile of earth of land on earth
that's not covered by ice or water so
the the land that is devoted to raising
animals for food either growing crops to
feed them or grazing them is greater
than the total
area of North America South America
Australia and Europe combined that's how
much land we're using for this and
that's all land that once supported
biodiversity diverse plants and animals
that's basically now been homogenized to
a few crops and the kinds of grasses
that can sustain intense grazing so this
industry it's overwhelmingly responsible
for habitat destruction and global
deforestation for example in the Amazon
it's responsible for more than 90
percent of ongoing deforestation and and
you know that if you look at that image
you're thinking holy that that
beautiful Amazon was turned into this
kind of waste line but it's not just an
aesthetic issue you know we kind of take
for granted as I was saying about you
know how we help basically when mosses
appear that's the first time animals
could breathe we we depend on this
diversity of plants and animals to keep
this planet habitable to maintain the
ecosystems that refresh our air and
water and and just keep our planet and
us alive and healthy and 10,000 years
ago we shared this planet with with
nature and all its diverse plants and
animals by 1976 we had reduced the total
biomass of wild animals remaining on
earth by twofold and the cows alone the
cows that were being raised for food
outweighed every living wild animal on
earth terrestrial animal on Earth by a
factor of four that was 40 years ago and
it's getting worse
so whoops what happened there my my
slides were rapidly we has it we edited
in the past hour or so and just realized
a slight error but anyway
today 2018 the total biomass of wild
animals living on earth is less than
half what it was 40 years ago so in the
past 40 years we've wiped out half the
wild animals that were living on earth
and it's for all practical purposes
entirely due to the use of animals of
food technology on land it's the
expansion of animal farming
overwhelmingly responsible for a
destruction of habitat and and
ecosystems and in water of course it's
overfishing so it's our use of animals
of food production technology that has
basically reduced the number of wild
animals living on earth by a factor of 2
and today the cows that are being raised
for food at this moment outweigh every
living land animal on Earth by more than
a factor of 10 and the pigs that are
being raised for food outweigh every
living wild animal on land by a factor
of 2 and chickens outweigh every living
wild bird remaining by a factor of 3 so
we've basically been pushing nature and
all the creatures that we depend upon
for stable ecosystems that keep this
planet thriving and keep us alive
practically to the edge of oblivion you
know if we if we reduce wild animals by
the by the amount that we did in the
past 40 years there'd be zip left and
and the reason is you know the demand
for meat basically that the biomass that
we consume annually is so great that if
we decided that we were going to as
people have suggested to me pretty
frequently well maybe we should just
hunt animals for our meat if we went to
that model there would be no wild
animals at all left on earth in two
months so basically we'd wipe them all
out
not a single mouse or shrew or or
squirrel left on earth in two months so
that's not a solution anyway this is
just to give you I'm not trying to bum
you out of
it's to give you an idea of of why as
soon as I learned about this problem I
thought I'm going to give up the best
job in the world and do what I can to
fix it
and and that's kind of the one take-home
lesson that if if there is a take-home
lesson from any of this is that you know
when I looked at this problem and
realize what a big deal it was I looked
around
actually I my first instinct was okay
someone's got to do something about this
so it didn't seem like anyone was doing
something about it so I'm gonna go
around and try to convince someone to
take this problem on and I went around
to food conferences and stuff like that
I said someone this is a huge
opportunity for someone it's a huge
problem and a huge opportunity someone
is gonna make a bundle of money if they
take on this problem and and the people
there you know whatever pepsi-cola and
so forth were just like come on and and
that's the point that I mean I think
this isn't a point to convey if you see
a problem there's this sort of a natural
instinct that someone else is working on
it or someone else is responsible for
solving it but don't assume that because
they don't know that responsible for
solving it and if you don't see that
someone is working on it it's a
reasonable bet that no one is working on
it and if it's not their responsibility
who is is it it's your responsibility as
much as anyone elses and if you care
about a big problem you know it's you
can't just say well someone else should
fix it it's your responsibility okay and
and since it's a business conference
I'll just parenthetically note that
usually when there's a big problem to
solve if you can figure out a solution
there's money to be made so okay the
problem was that that I wanted to fix
was this massive
scale of the the system we used to
produce food from animals and what made
it a real problem is that for most of
the people on earth for for billions of
people the food that we get from animals
is really an essential part of the
pleasure of living there they're not
going to be willing to sacrifice
something that contributes as much as as
meat and fish and dairy foods do to
their quality of life and even when I've
gone to these environmental conferences
that you know there is like lifelong
environmentalists as far as the eye can
see every single one of them is going
out for a steak after the conference and
I'm not kidding and they're not there
they're wonderful people and they
understand the problem and they're not
being about it it's just that
it's really really hard to make major
changes in diet the diet that you've had
all your life and you just have to
accept that we are not going to solve
this problem by persuading people to
change their diets or making it a moral
or political issue total waste of time
and unfortunately I can't see anyone
here but I was going to do a Q&A so if
you're in the audience don't worry I
can't see your face so I won't judge you
do you love meat yeah all right good
future customers so and and and now do
you love meat in part because of the way
we make it from animal cadavers is that
is that part of what you value in the
meat it's a serious question actually no
okay
do you love meat in spite of the way we
make it yes okay good
you're you're that's that's virtually
everywhere I've gone about around the
world pretty much that's including
middle America that's the way people
feel about it
they love their meat they're never going
to give up eating it but they don't love
the the way that it's made
just live with it and that really
defines the problem in in a useful way
oh and this business about 1.5 trillion
dollars this is why it was possible I
think for me to raise money for this
project okay and this is really the way
to look at the problem the problem isn't
that people love meat of course they
love meat it's that we're making it the
wrong way and the solution is to develop
a better way of making all the foods
that we get from animals but not just
something that's almost good enough in
order to succeed we need to make foods
that consumers around the world
decisively prefer based on all the
characteristics that that give it value
to them taste nutrition affordability
convenience and so forth if we can do
that if we can if we can do a better job
in the cow of making the best meat in
the world and just put it on the market
that's that's the most decisive way to
solve the problem
sorry and just as a quick analogy
although I think this is pretty
intuitive to you you know for tens of
thousands of years horses were the
definitive technology for for powered
transportation and if you ask someone to
two hundred years ago what the future of
Transportation looked like they highly
likely would have told you the horses
will probably be faster and then the
first mechanized transportation came
along in 1830 this is a first commercial
locomotive and it famously ran a race
with a horse in 1830 and lost slightly
lost to the horse but the important
point here is that it never lost again
because the horse never got faster and
once you switch to a technology from a
completely unimprovable technology like
basically animal
as as power or as food - one that is
improvable in multiple dimensions as
soon as you're running close the race is
over you know you're gonna win okay so
okay I'll talk fast so so this this
impossible food started out as a mission
and the mission basically wants to
replace the world's most destructive
technology by 2035 by making the most
delicious nutritious affordable meats
fish and dairy foods in the world and
and letting the market do the rest
this this became a company the mission
of getting rid of this technology became
a company when I realized that the
solution was market based and the first
step was convincing someone to invest in
this as a business which I had never
done before but fortunately I happen to
live on the Stanford campus which was
within short biking distance of half the
venture capital in the world and so I
could just in a less than 10 minute bike
ride pop over to Khosla Ventures and
knock on their door didn't really do
that but walk in and and gave my pitch
and it was it was a completely
amateurish pitch deck and it's kind of
like I'm going to show it to some people
at the company at some point because
it's so embarrassing in retrospect but
but basically this was my this was my
first slide it was about mission and the
next nine slides were about the mission
and why it was so important and it was
not until the tenth slide that I said
anything about how this could function
as a business but fortunately that tenth
slide basically had you know one
trillion dollars on it which was that
magical moment when they reach for their
checkbooks and anyway when I when I
launched the company I should also add
what I knew for sure was that the
was going to succeed I was I I knew I
believed it was totally doable and I was
completely determined I was not gonna
let this fall short of complete success
but I didn't know how we were gonna do
it I just knew it was doable and it was
evident from my deck that I really
didn't know how I was gonna do it and I
also didn't know how to run a business
as it was obvious to the investors once
they saw how bad a job I did of pitching
to them but anyway this is another slide
in my my pitch deck to just get move
this on which was you know some ideas
about how we might do this and and what
the technology would look like and one
of the ideas was at this I'm not gonna
go into the science behind this you can
ask he might be the magic ingredient for
flavor
and and I had this what I thought was a
brilliant idea which is that there's
this heme heme is the thing that makes
your blood red and carries oxygen in
your blood and it's found it but it's
found in lots of high crimes and animals
low quantities and plants but the one
place in plants were there's a decent
amount of it is in what's called the
root nodules of nitrogen-fixing plants
there's a protein called leg hemoglobin
that has heme and and I thought I did a
calculation I realized that there's
enough leg hemoglobin in the root
nodules of the US soybean crop to
replace all the heme and all the meat in
the u.s. diet and I thought holy crap
this is such a great idea well we'll
just once they harvest the soybeans will
come come across the field and harvest
the root nodules and it'll cost us
almost nothing and and and it's it's
genius
these are these aren't root nodules you
can just see kind of open they look like
meat inside a small amount of pea root
nodules like one ounce of pea root
nodules you can get all this red juice
that team okay so then the first year of
the company we spent probably more than
half of our startup investment pursuing
this idea which involved basically
making multiple trips to Texas and
Minnesota disobeyin farms and amassing
these giant piles of soybean roots and
developing these root
Goldberg contraptions to recover the
root nodules and extract the leg
hemoglobin from them and after actually
more than a year we realized this is a
ridiculous idea and what we'd spent like
a million dollars discovering that and
but it wasn't a waste of time for a
couple of reasons first of all the only
way that we could learn that this wasn't
the best way to do it was to try it and
realize it was a terrible way to do it
it was also a great way to build a team
because there's no better way to to
build a team than than to be you know
working on this kind of ridiculous
project where you find yourself with
your you know small group of colleagues
at the start of the company at 4 a.m.
you know mopping up the floor of some
godforsaken pilot facility in South
Texas it really helped us you know bond
as a team but we realized that wasn't
the way to do it we figured out a way to
produce heme using yeast and that
enabled our R&D team to establish what
we'd sort of only suspected which is
heme is the magic molecule that makes me
taste like meat it's basically the
explanation for why meat recognizably
tastes like meat and unlike anything
else on earth and it does it by
catalyzing chemical reactions that turn
these simple nutrients into flavor
molecules and so forth I won't go into
the science you can ask me about but but
anyway and so that was just part of the
science that went into you know the the
job that we assigned ourselves was study
meat the way I would in my previous life
have studied the disease to figure out
in molecular terms how it works and then
once you know that to figure out how to
how to make the best version of it you
know using a new set of tools the R&D
team which was the best group of
scientists ever assembled in the food
food world by far did that task and and
then ok and about two years ago we we
decided we knew enough to launch our
first product
which was raw ground beef which we chose
because it's the most disruptive product
we thought we could make in the US and
and and again here's how I know we're
going to succeed here okay so this
product they were serving it in the food
trucks I encourage you to try it and
email us if you have any any comments on
it but but here's how we how I know
we're going to succeed
basically the cow has been working on
this for a million years and we've been
working on it for about six years and at
this point I would say by a lot of
criteria were running even with the cow
okay so this is like where mechanized
transportation was in 1830 and we're
getting better every day and the cow is
not
and this just the mission here the
original motivation or a big part of it
was to reduce the environmental impact
of the food system and even at this
early stage where we haven't really
fully optimizes for sustainability
producing our burger based on
independent lifecycle analysis use the
quarter of the water an eighth of
greenhouse gas emissions and less than
one twentieth the land to produce the
same thing from a cow and that's going
to get better
so okay 30 seconds more today there are
people who are actually talking about
you know the need to establish a human
colony on Mars so that will be ready in
case we totally mess up this planet in
case we make earth uninhabitable but the
thing is that Mars is already
uninhabitable an earth is awesome and
all we need to do is to keep from
turning earth into Mars and we're good
and so
anyway so this is the plant that I'm
going to bet on and and it's this that
gets me excited to go to work every day
and the other reason is this I
absolutely love all the people that I
get to work with every day and that's it
thank you
[Applause]